the father of a five-year-old cancer
patient will not be deported for at
least a year hey Zeus Bironas was
granted a temporary stay yesterday just
hours after we shared his story Manuel
Bojorquez was with Peyronie's as he wait
as he awaited his fate he is outside the
Phoenix Arizona Church that gave
sanctuary to the undocumented immigrant
men well good morning good morning has
Zeus barone has sought refuge inside
this church Friday when it appeared he
would be deported he refused to leave
yesterday as the deadline to turn
himself in passed after an agonizing day
of waiting the father of five learned he
would be allowed to stay in the US for
at least another year jaden Bironas
couldn't contain his excitement the
five-year-old who is battling leukemia
learned his father would not be deported
his seuss Bironas his application for a
stay was denied last week by US
Immigration and Customs Enforcement the
agency reversed itself Monday citing
humanitarian grounds Bironas and his
ten-year-old daughter Ottilie were
overwhelmed i'ma get to get to go home
women kissing my wife his wife Sonia is
five months pregnant
handling Jaden's cancer drugs puts her
and her baby at risk she was excited his
sous was granted a one-year stay Bironas
was brought from Mexico as a toddler in
1989 he has been deported twice in 2006
and 2010 returning to the US illegally
each time in February 2016 he was
sentenced to 90 days in federal prison
on a criminal misdemeanor charge Bironas
his wife and children are all US
citizens he was due to be deported
Monday what do you say to people who
think you're here illegally that means
you should not be here I've been here
okay I feel like I'm from here the 30
year old undocumented immigrant has to
regularly check in with the local ice
office he also can get a driver's
license and a work permit for a year
according to his lawyer Garrett Wilks he
used to go he gets to go home Peter's
family tonight without any worry that
someone's gonna come to his house
Bironas thought he might have to live at
the church for at least a few months he
now plans to apply for citizenship a
process which can take years but there
is no guarantee ice will give him
another stay once this one expires Nora
all right Manuel thank you